hello world DB destroyer Sinclair here
with Randy Marnell creative director of
gearbox software guys and we're here
with Kelman awesome ice monster Calvin
is a Kevin's really really cool a show
them off here Kelvin is a giant ice and
stone kind of Gollum rock monster
another male a defender here battle
board and loves they get in close mix it
up have some great punching moves a big
round pounds does area effect damage
chomps can turn into mist in the skill
sublimate show some really cool stuff
here on these midgets alright so we
picked a little group here a little
threesome to support each other's
through this level and we're doing it as
a three-player cooperative gang here if
you will but this could be played up to
five players cooperatively frightened we
also have 5v5 multiplayer modes as well
but today we are showing off the single
player or cooperative story-driven mode
here and Kelvin Nico with the heels and
of course Marquis here and I'm dropping
that that anti sniper sniper vs sniper
here to give you guys a little room to
work with great I really appreciate that
there's a yeah there are some definitely
some snipers at the end of this area
that it's been a difficult I'm going to
drop back for a second let you guys
continue to snipe on that I want to i
need to activate a piece of my gear for
Kelvin it's going to help out actually a
my gear load out on this one I picked
another flawed Colin these sketchy
Boilermakers have zero activation cost
mean I'm going to get some movement
speed just based movement speed right
out the door the beginning of the match
it's only 5% but that really makes a big
difference on some of these lumbering
melee characters letting me get to get
in a puzzle before you can snipe them
all out that's really important
alright so you went mailing you went up
close and personal this is a map and a
story mission that does happen to have
some pretty strong sniper support as far
as the enemy side is concerned so we
brought mark opinion to help out with
the range and then Miko of course is
bringing the heels now not only did we
want to help each other out with the
damage department but I'm also playing
into some helix choices that are going
to help you out as well so on the top of
my helix I went with waste makes haste
so my temporal distortion move is not
only going to slow enemies it now
Hastings my allies as well so thirty
percent movement speed 44 seconds to you
guys and I know that you're spending
into a bit of a movement speed as well
to get you in and out of the action
that's right in fact let me go ahead and
take a couple of my abilities here I'm
going to do some things now kevin has a
lot of control in him so what other
things I want to do I'm going to take
some to be sure that my melee also slows
down opponents I'm going to take a idea
over here oh I love increases my
movement speed when I Chomp Chomp every
time I chopped the enemy you see Calvin
kind of clothes in with this mouth I
every time I chopped an enemy it's gonna
if I kill the enemy of the chop it
actually stacks health permanently on
Calvin turns them into a juggernaut by
the end of the match very cool alright
so here we go we got the juggernaut we
got the well you know what this actually
brings us to a very interesting point so
Niko and Kelvin they share sort of some
similar I don't even know how to put it
into words they they have some uh some I
guess a bonding moment you might say
it's kind of gross to put that way the
hell but I see what you did oh yeah yeah
yeah no miko you know we've talked about
miko part of this giant mushroom planet
there's a
score last of a species from what used
to be a giant a sentient planet right
Kelvin is also a member of a collective
species but Kelvin is actually a group
of microscopic organisms that all join
together to kind of Express a single
personality Miko and kevin has been
crammin kind of being a part of a hive
collective and so they stay a good
friend like it this kind of a have my
people call your people type of thing so
that said though as a robot Butler I'm a
little wary of this giant collection of
organisms crawling around you know the
the butler in me just wants to clean up
after you but instead i am going to lend
some some snipe support some moss
pensive support here whoops yeah what's
cool with that is watching some got this
ability sublimate this guy that you're
having trouble with here well you sleep
thinking about I can turn myself into
this kind of ball of ross can move
around the map I'm just going to slow or
stun enemies which is going to make it
easier for you to get in there and
actually take them out as a sniper me
minions kind of crit spot right in the
eyes you can get that does its kind of
damage I definitely need the slow down
to help with that that's for sure all
right here we go here come these first
waves since we've taken down that pesky
shard back there I'm gonna slow these
guys down for you for a little bit and
you're able to go in there and attack
them all as a group so so far this is
paid off as a pretty strong and
significant trio as long as our healer
keeps his his he lives
like she's doing a pretty great job of
so far I think you did a great job I'm
Kelvin as an elder it starts off with no
shields you can see here I've actually
picked up an over shield pickup which
gives me a temporary over shield yeah
but it's another thing I'm gonna watch
the appellant player just a way to give
me extra survivability and kind of that
defensive defender rolled alright so
moving along here we're gonna have a bit
of a boss fight on our hands once we
clear out these first couple of ways
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and sublimate go
in here and hit these waves so you've
already picking them out i was going to
slow down for you but you didn't need
that up top of the marquee so what i
found is that there's some pretty
convenient little explodable crate type
things throughout the levels and these
are really good for using with marky
with that long shot if the enemy is sort
of grouped up around there to explode
them into smithereens yeah barking has a
really great and kind of playing that
support sniper role stay in the back
really being sure that that enemies are
even soft enough and when you can't take
them out for the team I'm going to watch
out like these boom box or a great
chance to use Marquis in the level
because they come up close to you and
explode I don't want that to happen as a
melee character so having you there is
really great i'm going to activate one
more piece of gear here I've got enough
shards that I can actually activate this
big damage reduction piece of gear again
is a male a brawler it's going to be
really effective for Kelvin it lets me
get up close and not worry quite as much
about these guys I try to get my chomp
kill stacks together yeah there we go
AOE damage is my out of my left trigger
ability like round town cleaning up
these intimate with minions
so we're talking about the different
ways you can use that that trauma to to
stack higher and higher health and one
of the modes and talk about it might be
good in would be in the minion meltdown
multiplayer mode if you can get some
nice chunks there and also good against
the minions and the various bosses that
we're fighting here in the co-operative
story mode and here they come yeah this
is hinchman a pretty nasty boss here and
the boys edge
it's right here Kurt wants a piece of my
kids all right I'm going to kind of jump
down through here I'm going to slow him
down now watch this I've got an ultimate
a lot for Kelvin right here it's not
really going to help us stop myself
Lisbon but what I will do he's going to
try to move around and close in on some
characters I don't wanted to close it on
me cose what I'm going to do is I'm
going to wall off Nico over there I keep
oh nice frost walls the kind of keep
hinchman lock of magenta corner not a
strong hitchman he kind of jumped from
position to position but when you're
definitely having like waves of minions
or in a PDP when guys are following you
around being able to put that wall down
and a pinch really handy keeping your
funeral I've while you're trying to go
in and fix it up close very cool
especially when you don't have it a
shield and B now he does not start with
that does not have that shield unless
he's getting an over shield
the are henchman and his buddy into
t.o.o too also you notice that every
once at all we are getting some minions
a trickle into the spy kind of adding
the boss strange I'm still taking every
opportunity I can to take that chump and
shop and get a chop some of the millions
every time I do that it adds health
bonuses to tell them so again tell them
play is all about just by the Kinsler
fight becoming an unstoppable juggernaut
and it's great all that help and I've
got Mico behind me keeping my help
topped off as much as possible because
put its ultimate down there that great
mushroom hood the stealing all the group
really let's just go up and mix it in
I'm gonna get right in between these two
and use my area of effect damage both of
them get a ground pound I think
sublimate slow them down for you get a
little bit of an exhibition so it's
probably worth mentioning them if you
playing Kelvin and you're going for
those those chomps those last tips if
you will that's something you definitely
want to communicate to your teammates so
that your you know they're not stealing
the kills from you because especially
when I'm playing someone like Marky ok
I'm going for those headshots every time
absolutely in fact we just I missed the
opportunity there of things you were
talking I could talk over you because we
just killed off hinchman one and the
perfect little sliver of hell that would
have been a big major kill that's been a
nice stack there let's see if we can
time it better on hitchman to hear I'm
gonna drop that wall back there to use
it why not right now yeah cuz if we can
time it right I can actually set you up
for those last kills earned those last
hits all right close close that job and
here comes the chop
yeah i think i got it in yes I did huge
health boost up into that on the child
took out both the henchman's great fight
guys I mean there's no better time than
now for a taunt I suppose oh yeah here
we go sublimate and then going to show
off Kelvin one more time Chomp Chomp
ladies and gentlemen that is battle born
that was Kelvin you want to see more
battle born videos you want to go to
youtube battle born gay man digging the
videos please don't hesitate to
subscribe to the channel you can find
battle born on twitter at battle born
you can also find me on twitter if
that's something you were dying to do at
poon Trank dome and Randy tell us where
we can find you sure the name i'm
playing here a jitt 3 is my twitter
handle jy T HR I've and you can also
find a gearbox software on Twitter
Gearbox Software just like that and
battleborn images alright thank you so
much guys for watching the video and we
will be back soon with more battle born